make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so the power supply for my EGP you
fried my macbook pro had a hardware
failure that i had to take it in haven't
shipped off for repair everything's
failing in my home right now what's
going on guys this is Rob and we're
covering part three of absolute carnage
in part two really parts 1 and part 2
because remember part like the the first
issue split into three parts the first
two parts it was basically panic mode
right it was the idea that Cletus Kasady
had essentially returned now the way
that Donnie Cates had written this is a
Cletus Kasady had been coming back for a
while it's just that right now Eddie
Brock just realized what was really
happening right he just realized they
liked Cletus Kasady he made his return
and I love the way the Donnie Cates
wrote that right because before the
person who's kind of getting into
carnage and doesn't really know anything
about the character it's like cool a new
symbian for people who are familiar with
with carnage it's like cool in old
symbian and a lot of people are going to
die but it's one of these things were
kind of like your dedication and and
your sort of time spent with the
character of Cletus Kasady over the
years it's kind of rewarded right
because like this is the return this is
like the joke if the Joker got the venom
Samiha right like a crazy person becomes
venom and then like loses their minds
but the idea behind this is that we're
basically dealing with with them going
and grabbing Norman Osborn now we talked
about this in the last video and what
kind of refresh it a little bit for
those of you guys who are you know kind
of coming into this so if you're
watching the full story version of this
what kind of be repeating ourselves for
a second but the idea behind Norman
Osborn becoming the the really the red
goblin I the carnage and the the Goblin
a concept was to kind of try to
reinvigorate Norman Osborn right to kind
of like give him a new status quo after
the events of Dark Reign in reality you
don't really need to right there are
some villains out there in the realm of
comic books the Joker
Lex Luthor characters like like Norman
Osborn who's probably well he's not
certainly the most iconic spider-man
villain I'd say he's probably the most
important and so what they did is that
his Marvel basically said let's give him
the card symbiote and then in turn have
him bring back the Green Goblin so he
basically becomes the red goblin and it
was really popular for a little while
right like it's one of the more popular
stories involving the various symbiote
so I would say it's more popular because
it involves a symbiote as opposed to
just the Green Goblin himself but again
he's a legacy villain right so it's one
of those things you have to really
change all that often what you end up
having here is spider-man and you have
venom who basically race off to grab
Norman Osborn and this is kind of an
important thing here right because with
Norman Osborn as the red goblin I
wouldn't say he pushed the symbiote to
new heights by
virtue of like his intelligence and so
on and so forth it was really more like
merging with the Green Goblin and the
Venom symbiote that kind of pushes the
new heights but Norman Osborn is not an
unintelligent guy and the real question
the idea behind this is that with venom
really realizing what's going on and
this idea that Cletus Kasady is running
around and tracking these code X's right
like trying to kill the various
individuals who have been the simian
host the question is we kind of have to
save Norman Osborn now it's interesting
here because all on the surface you
would say well then let him die right
I've just let Norman Osborn die and it's
one of those funny things because it's
really more of the moral quagmire of
venom and spider-man what kind of
superheroes would they be if they just
let Norman Osborn die but I mean that's
kind of the issue that you run into here
what kind of heroes would they be if
they let this guy die and that was
basically the end of it and so again
it's kind of intriguing because in the
midst of all this suddenly you end up
having spider-man who goes nuts and this
is one of the more important things that
Donnie Cates is doing here again we
talked about this in the first couple
parts and it bears repeating here but
the idea is that in in years past right
going all the way back to like even you
gotta like David McLean II is um
original like venom lethal protector but
like you go all the way back to like
when when carnage was first introduced
and even before that when venom was
introduced and all the various simius
between them right like scream and and
riot and all those guys the way this
always worked and was kind of itching
stoned by venom is that when a person
becomes a host the symbiote can leap
right like if bite you know by whatever
manner and whatever means if the
symbiote leaves the Scindia takes
memories of that person with them right
so that was the case of venom knowing
the identity of Peter Parker the Venom
symbiote had bonded to Peter it was cast
off eleven spider-man 45 and then it
bonded itself to Eddie Brock taking the
knowledge of Peter Parker's identity
identity of spider-man with it and so
the reason why that's important is
because what this does is it basically
allows Donnie Cates to build on that
concept and say actually what happens is
for all those individuals who have been
a host of the carnage symbiote it leaves
back at least behind itself a kind of
sample right like a kind of little
genetic code that the the kind of Samiha
that Cletus Kasady can tap into now the
big question to ask her this is kind of
a big thing to come out of this kin
venom do the same thing can they tap
into and can they basically control the
minds of other individuals by using that
genetic code one of the other big
changes that Donna Cates is making here
is Carnage's ability to spawn more
symbionts what Cletus is doing here is
basically creating these little mini
pods and then they're forcing themselves
into various prisons going into the
bodies of those particular prisoners and
then basically creating more
Simeon's so to speak now it's kind of
interesting here because these aren't
really carnage symbionts in the
traditional sense which is to say
they're not really like duplicates of
himself they're really more akin to like
children and that's why this is a school
because if you look at this it looks
like you literally have Donna Cates
building up this army of soldiers more
or less for carnage who in turn can
allow him to try to defeat Nullah
symbiote god that's kind of where I hope
this is going to but you end up having
carnage in spider-man and venom all
teaming up to face off against a null
and then like truly and successfully to
feed him like it'd be kind of cool but
it's kind of one of these funny things
because as that goes off you know as
this begins to go down you end up having
a course a sound system is triggered and
then with the sound system being
triggered as we know with with symbionts
they hate like loud sonic vibrations and
so where Eddie goes to take them out it
allows him and Peter to basically team
up and try to face off against the
forces of carnage but that's where
things begin to go awry because at the
outset you simply expect it to just be
Cletus Kasady right now you expected to
just be him and go walking in because
the reality of this is that you go back
and you look at like maximum carnage the
maximum carnage storyline you go back
and look at the time that like Eddie
Anne and spider-man first fought venom
before maximum carnage and you're
talking about a simian out there that's
stronger than the two of them right so
Cletus Kasady alone would be enough to
overtake and and to basically defeat
spider-man and venom and so this is
designed to illustrate one or two things
or possibly both the first is that it's
design to basically show that like all
these different characters are designed
to show up and basically cause absolute
pandemonium
right like bolstering the numbers of
carnage this forces the other half of
this and this is what I think is
actually a little more interesting is
that Cletus Kasady is getting arrogant I
can send my forces forward and have them
do it for me now in reality if Cletus
Kasady is getting carried away for
themselves and if he's being arrogant
then it's with good reason because you
basically have like all these different
forces that are pretty much overtaking
venom and and spider-man and they're
doing a pretty darn good job at it right
I mean that's kind of the nature of
things is you're talking about these
exceedingly strong and powerful versions
of carnage really like more of the
Grindle's than anything else they're
just kind of ripping things up and so in
the midst of all this or Peter kind of
get to see no throne to you know throw
into the side he's met by the arrival of
Cletus and that's when things really get
scary right because Cletus is a man
without reason and that's what makes
Cletus so dangerous is because of the
fact that he's a believer but he
believes that what he's doing is right
he believes that what he's doing is the
correct
to do and you can't sway him from that
belief he's a guy that just cannot be
changed and so what happens when you
give a person who cannot be changed the
power to force change onto other people
they're gonna do exactly that they're
going to basically create a litany of
reasons for why you're wrong and then
force their entire perspective on to you
right so either you can reject it or you
can accept it but you're not going to be
able to get them to change what it is
that they're doing and that's what's so
cool about this is because you basically
have like like venom fighting off
against Peter and it's one of these cool
little moments because when that happens
then I'm actually sort of chastised as
Peter for a second and says stop being
clever stop being funny stop cracking
jokes this is time for business and
that's an important thing but one of the
things that Dan Slott established during
the original spider-man renew your vows
as part of Secret Wars is there's a
reason why Peter does this but there's
no reason to do it here one of the big
questions people had all the time for it
for years and years and years Peter
would crack jokes in the middle of
fights and and people always sort of
attributed that to the fact that Peter
was just a character who would joke
around but there's a reason for why
Peter does this so really it took
decades to get to the point we could
actually get an explanation to it but
during the original renew your vows Dan
Slott stated that the reason why Peter
does that is because it throws his enemy
off right it frustrates is enemy and
makes them angry because the enemy
believes Peter doesn't respect them
right like I'm not I'm not taking this
fight seriously because you're not
really anybody to worry about this is
business as usual and you're of no real
concern to me that's the message Peter
puts off right the ID other idea is to
kind of keep things loose and to keep
you from getting carried away keep him
from getting like super overexcited and
and and to kind of keep him grounded and
in the moment but it's as much so like
screw with the other guy the issue with
this is that with cletus kasady
that don't work that dog don't bark
right because cletus kasady doesn't take
the bait that's the nature of cletus
kasady is about as crazy you know I'm
not really as crazy he's crazier than
spider-man
so like cracking jokes going on about
nonsense it doesn't really work and
that's why venom says it's not the time
to be clever it's not the time to be
funny it's not the time to like crack
jokes and be your usual self this is the
time to be serious because if we're not
we could die here today and Peter knows
that but venom doesn't know that Peter
knows that it's just Peters way of doing
things it's kind of how Peter is and so
following this the two of them are
basically like knocked out of the cell
you know sent flying out into the
hallway and that's when Peter basically
begs for carnage not to kill Norman
Osborn and that's what he says I'm not
here to kill him I'm here to add him to
my forces it's literally carnage
absorbing Norman Osborn into himself and
basically turning Norman Osborn
into one of his various henchmen now
Norman Osborn has not have the Grendel
insignia on his forehead and the
indication here is that Norman Osborn is
something wholly new like it may be that
he's something wholly different and
wholly new probably not he's probably
just just like all the other ones right
there's nothing really special about him
but I have a hard time believing Donnie
Cates wouldn't wouldn't have him
depicted in this manner if he wasn't
different from everybody else so I'm
really excited I'm really curious to see
where it goes oh that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explain
and make sure you guys at the sub button
- become part of the Rob for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you